les soviétiques compte annoncer
aujourd'hui que 84 mille personnes ont
déjà été évacuées des environs de
tchernobyl
la presse occidentale ne peut toujours
pas se rendre sur place mais certains
journalistes ont pu accéder à kiev à 130
km de là parmi eux le correspondant de
l'agencé france presse
l'année scolaire et jeudi prochains cent
cinquante mille enfants de 7 à 14 ans
elle voit recommander et que ledit de
vacances hors de la ville
ce n'est pas une évacuation affirme le
maire et la nuit dernière on pouvait
voir rigueur de vendre autant à partir
avec des bébés phoques adultes
accompagnés d'un enfant de moins de 10
ans a reçu l'autorisation de s'éloigner
de la capitale de l'ukraine nous a
confirmé le président de la diète à
tanger mais beaucoup de précaution les
yeux et la bouche et les rues
l'hippodrome car on résout à quatre
partout la radioactivité de l'air et de
l'eau et mesurer toutes les heures et où
40 seulement aux gens la population
seulement une tour l'inquiétude dans
toutes les conversations
et beaucoup de questions pour les jours
c'est même mêmes - avenue vers le cloud
caire afp audio